foreign
s in Louisville Kentucky hi William how
are you
I'm doing good Dave how are you doing
better than I deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call um and Rachel
too uh my question is uh we're looking
for for guidance on how much we should
spend on our on our next home uh we're
debt free and we've got a paid off house
right now and I'm saving up for a next
and bigger home and I'm just looking at
it's for recommendations on how much we
should spend on that as like maybe as a
percentage of our net worth or where
you're at on guidance you know going
into that bigger home category so you're
paying cash
for the upgrade we're saving cash for
the upgrade but we've got a this house
right now could probably net 350. and
we're looking at homes in the you know
five to 750 range and uh we've got
probably another 100 saved up for that
one but we're not you know we're not to
where we can pay cash for the next one
yet okay are you planning to wait until
you do or you're going to take out a
small mortgage and then pay it off
well originally I was I wanted to wait
and then you know now uh we had we just
had our fifth uh kid here uh two months
ago and we're you know more than
outgrowing the house that we're in and I
think we're all ready for for something
new and
and you know I could I could save 25 to
40
000 per year towards a new one but it's
going to be you know 8-10 years before I
think I could get into
you know into
having it having all the cash flow to
answer your question yes I'd probably go
get a loan first now what's your
household in the Gap in between this
what's your house about 100 150 000.
okay okay
well yeah are you I mean the way I would
look at it is okay what can I get for
the house how much cash do I have
putting all those numbers together and
then saying you know if it's that
mortgage payment you can go back to that
25 of your take-home pay on a 15-year
fixed rate that's kind of our formula
for
for a house and drone but you're putting
down a massive massive payment down
payment
um because of everything you're going to
have from your from your current home
and what you have saved
um so yeah I would I would look at those
numbers and then I would run out to a
time frame to say man we want to be if
we can do this and we can be debt free
again in
four years or whatever whatever it may
be so that you can pay it down quickly
uh I would factor that timeline in as
well William and and talk to your wife
how many kids do you guys have five
we just had we just had ourselves we
just had your fifth I'm sorry okay
yeah so um what do you do for a living
uh I work in uh engineering and uh
construction good for you okay
the um
and you ask what percentage of your net
worth uh when you've got a uh a net
worth of under a million
um you know your house is going to be
the larger percentage of your net worth
typically
when you especially when you work
towards a paid for house okay and so
um you know like we had a young couple
last hour doing their debt free scream
their house is 60 percent of their 70 of
their net worth uh they just paid off
their house and so um that's not gonna
be unusual you wouldn't want that high
the higher your net worth the smaller
the percentage would go to your house
if you have a hundred million dollar net
worth you wouldn't want sixty percent to
your house you know that'd be weird
you see what I'm saying so even a 10
million even a 10 million dollar net
worth you wouldn't but in your first
million of net worth
um you know it's going to be the larger
share it's going to be 50 North of 50
probably uh wouldn't be that unusual but
the good news is the house isn't going
to go up and you're going to be once
you've gotten that house paid off you're
going to be chunking into retirement and
so by the time you get to 2 million
it'll be 30 percent
or something like that and uh so
you know your the natural tendency is
going to be your other Investments are
growing faster than the house because
you're adding to those after you get the
house paid off and so um yeah that as
far as your net worth question goes it
sounds like everything you're doing is
very safe and you're fine just put it on
a shorter term as you possibly can
maximum of 15 years maximum of 25 of
your take-home pay but I think you're
going to be well below the 15 year you
might want to do the full 25 and then
even more beyond that uh but I'd set the
payment up at 25 on a shorter term as
that will allow given the given the
price you buy with the down payment you
have and if that means you do an eight
year loan fine if it means you're doing
a six year loan fine that's fine put
tenure put on that that's fine just put
it out there 25 and then throw extra
above that on it but your actual
commitment monthly don't let that be any
higher than 15 other than 25 percent of
your take on pay so you're doing good
man you doing good you're thinking about
it you're way ahead you're not normal
you're already weird congratulations